Imagine a volcano spewing frozen lava at negative
182 degrees celsius!
Well, that’s just another day on Ceres.
Hello Earthlings, Ian here for DNews and I
want to tell you about some VERY cool planetary
science.
Cryovolcanoes — or “ice volcanoes” — are
purely extraterrestrial affairs and are thought
to be pretty common on the moons and dwarf
planets of the outer solar system.
NASA’s Cassini mission, for example, has
spotted possible ice volcanoes on Saturn’s
moon Titan.
And the New Horizons mission to Pluto has
also seen features that could be created by
cryovolcanic activity.
Now, NASA has announced that even Ceres, the
closest dwarf planet to the sun, has an ice
volcano mystery going on!
You may think you’re pretty familiar with
volcanoes.
These ruptures in the Earth’s crust form
at the edges of tectonic plates, venting molten
rock from our planet’s mantle, spewing lava
over land and into the oceans and creating
new rock.
But things get a bit weird when we look elsewhere
in the solar system.
Sure, we know there are extinct volcanoes
on Mars and there are very, very active ones
on Jupiter’s angry moon Io, but cryovolcanoes
are something else altogether that you won’t
find on Earth.
These ice volcanoes are found on icy worlds.
And instead of erupting with molten rock,
they erupt volatiles like water, methane and
ammonia.
Volatiles are chemicals that have very low
melting points and for the most part remain
as a solid inside icy planets and moons.
For example, methane melts when heated to
MINUS 182 degrees Celsius.
As Earth is a pretty warm place, methane is
usually found as a gas here, but on super-cold
worlds like Pluto, it’s usually found as
solid ice.
BUT -- if something heats the interiors of
these worlds — like radioactive decay — methane
and other volatiles will melt and erupt to
the surface.
These eruptions can create the ice equivalent
of volcanoes that we are familiar with on
Earth; just swap out the superhot lava for
extremely cold liquid that spews onto the
surface, rapidly refreezing and creating a
volcano-like mountain.
If you were unfortunate to be standing next
to a cryovolcano as it erupted, you wouldn’t
be incinerated by molten rock, you’d be
frozen into a block of ice.
So, back to Ceres.
This strange dwarf planet is thought to contain
large quantities of water ice and now NASA’s
Dawn mission has spotted a solitary mountain,
nearly half the size of Mount Everest, that
is thought to be a cryovolcano.
This peculiar mountain is called Ahuna Mons
and scientists are trying to work out why
there appears to be only one.
It’s a bit like the Earth possessing just
one volcano — that doesn’t make much sense.
Although cryovolcanoes are still pretty theoretical,
it's thought that Ceres used to have more,
but they flattened out out via “viscous
relaxation”.
This physical process is known to cause masses
of ice to deform over time, and it’s the
same process that drives the flow of Earth’s
glaciers into the ocean.
Because of that process, over hundreds of
millions of years, ice-rich cryovolcanoes
are thought to slowly slump under gravity
and flatten out.
The only reason why Ahuna Mons is still standing
is that it is pretty young, geologically speaking.
This finding only adds strength to the idea
that there’s a LOT of water ice on Ceres,
but most of it is locked under the surface.
Want to know more about Ceres?
Check out Amy’s video here.
What do you think is more awesome -- an ice
volcano or a regular ol’ lava volcano?
Let us know down in the comments, subscribe,
and come back every day for more episodes.